[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استاهلوها بابرس
العنويه
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه للعربيه امريكا
اقدم حليف لنا لكن من المهم مد الجسور مع
الجميع
صانع قنبله نجوم لوكربي ابو عجيله مسعود
اختطف في ليبيا وظهر معتقلا في امريكا
التي تستعد للمحاكمه
وفي كردستان العراق ضغوط وانت تدفع نحو
حوار ينهي الخلافات السياسيه بين اكبر
حزبين في اربيل والسليمانيه
قبل حضره ترامب رئيس مجلس الاداره كان في
اجازه
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان
في لقاء خاص مع العربي انا الولايات
المتحده تبقى الحليف الاقدم للمملكه لكنه
شدد ايضا على اهميه المد الجسور مع الجميع
واشار الى ان المملكه تعزز شركاتها سواء
كانت القديمه تاريخيه اول شديده
ولايه المتحده الحليف الاقدم والاهم
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لكن يبقى ايضا
مهم ان مده الجسور مع الجميع وانفتح جميع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اسرع اقتصاد نمو
في العالم هذه السنه سوف نصل الى اقتصاد
ترليون دولار من الناتج المحلي في نهايه
السنه هذه كلها عناصر اقتصاد الخامس عشر
في طريقها الى ان يكون العاشر او اكبر كل
هذه عوامل تفرض علينا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ان نتوسع في شراكاتنا ان نعزي
الشراكاتنا ليس فقط الجديده لكن ايضا نعس
شراكاتنا القديمه والتاريخيه استاذ نستمر
على هذا المنوال ان شاء الله
واشار وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان ان قمم رياض كانت قائمه على اسس
راسخه لتعاوني مع الصين
خادم الحرمين الشريفين سمو ولي العهد
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه تبحث عن
الشركاء في كل الاطراف في المرحله الاولى
او في المقام الاول عن مصالحنا لكن نبحث
ايضا عن تحقيق مصالح مشتركه
من الرياض ينضم الينا الدكتور فهد بن جمعه
عضو مجلس الشورى السعوديه سابقا دكتور فهد
يعني سياسات التعاون المرن اليوم مع
الحفاظ على الشركات والتحالفات
الاستراتيجيه التاريخيه للمملكه الى اي
مدى هي مهمه وك- كما عبر عنها طبعا وزير
الخارجيه بهذا التصريح الذي سمعناه
مساء الخير عليك وعلى جميع المشاهدين
الكرام في غايه الاهميه
نحن العالم متغير ومتنوع ولابد ان تكون
العلاقات الدوليه والاقتصاديه متنوعه مع
جميع الاقطاب وجميع الدول حسب المصالح
والمنافع التي تحددها هذه الشركات
همم هذه الدول ومن اهم الولايات المتحده
والصين وغيرها هذه دول العظمى اااه لها
استثمارات في الشرق الاوسطها في السعوديه
والسعوديه لها استمارات
طويله فهي في غايه الاهميه
وتؤدي الى اكثر امان واستقرار في المنطقه
التنويع للتحصين والتحسين الاقتصادي
والتنموي همم ايضا كم هو مهم بالمرحله
المقبله وسط كل الازمات الاقتصاديه
العالميه
بالتاكيد كل ما يتنوع الاقتصاد وينمو
الاقتصاد كلما كانت العلاقات اقوى
وامتن لان الاقتصاد هو محدد اييه اساسي
للعلاقات الدوليه والحمد لله المملكه تشهد
نمو اقتصادي هو الاسرع في العالم وهذه
العلاقات الاقتصاديه
وتمركز النفط في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كلها تؤدي الى
مصالح مشتركه بين الاطراف وعامل جانب لهذه
الشراكه والاستثمارات نحو امن واستقرار
المنطقه خروج دول المنطقه من يعني التموضع
والتمركز الجان الجامد الى جانب القوى
الكبرى طبعا اتحدثون الى جانب قوه واحده
واغض الطرف عن القوه الاخرى خروجه من هذا
الجامد الى موضوع مرن يراعي مصالح المنطقه
كم هو مهم لمستقبل دول الخليج ودول العالم
العربي
والمتنوعه هي تؤدي الى الامان والاستقرار
في المنطقه عندما يكون هناك اي خلاف بين
دول الخليج والدول العربيه
ودوله ما فهناك دول اخرى تستطيع ان تتعامل
معها وتغطي او تعمل تسويه هذا الخلاء
لمصالح اقتصاد هذه الدول فهذه العلاقات كل
ما تنوعت كلما زادت المكان وكل مكان
الاستقرار
مستتب في المنطقه وفي العلاقات وهذا يدعم
التوازن الاقتصادي بين الدول ويحقق اعظم
المنافع لكل دوله ولكل دوله الحق ان تنوع
علاقاتها الاقتصاديه من اجل همم اقتصادها
ومن اجل همم شعبه
شكرا لك دكتور فهد بن جمعه عضو مجلس
الشورى السعودي سابقا على هذه المداخله
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان والاماراتيه الشيخ عبد الله بن
زايد مسارات التعاون الخليجيه العربي حيث
اكد الجانبان خلال اجتماعهما في ابو ظبي
على اهميه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه لدعم
الامن والاستقرار الاقليميه ودوليا وشدد
وزير الخارجيه الاماراتيه ان بلاده ترتبط
مع السعوديه
بشراكه قويه ومستدامه وتتعزز بشكل مستمر
مشيدا بنتائج القمم الرياض مع الصين
وانعكاساتها على استقرار المنطقه
[موسيقى]
حادثه تفجير الطائره الامريكيه فوق لوكربي
تعد مجددا الى الواجهه هذه المره عبر
الشخصيه الثالثه المتهم بصنع القنبله
المستخدمه بالهجوم واشنطن اعلنت عن اعتقال
ابو عجيله بعد اسابيع من اختطافه الغامض
في ليبيا بحسب عائلته واختفائه بحسب وزاره
العدل الليبيه
بانها سلمته للولايات المتحده
34 عاما مضت على اعلى في حادث ارهابي شهدت
الاراضي البريطانيه تفجير لاكر به الذي
راح ضحيته 270 شخصا لتبدا معها محطات
القضيه الابرص انطلاقا من عام 2003 حينما
اقرت ليبيا بمسؤوليتها عن حادث تفجير
اللكربي في اسكتلندا
توهاما بالضلوع في التخطيط وتصنيع قنبله
تتعلق بالارهاب لمواطن ليبي يدعى ابو عجيل
مسعود المغربي
امنعم الجاري فشاهده نوفمبر الماضي احداث
متسارعه اعاده قضيه اللقبي للواجهه بعد
الجدل الذي اثاره اختفاء ابو عجيل مسعود
في ظروف غامضه تقارير اعلاميه قالت انه
خططف من داخل السجن بالعاصمه طرابلس بينما
ظهر بيان وعائلته انه اختطف من منزله
ليطالب بعدها المجلس الاعلى للدوله حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
بدور الكاميرا
عبر بيان اصدرته وزاره العدل تطرقت فيه
لرفضها فتح ملف قضيه
معلنه انه اغلق بالكامل سياسيا وقانونيه
لكن دون ان تتطرق للتهم الموجهه لها او
ملابسات اختفاء ابو عجيله
اما روايه عائله ابو عجيله فكانت مناقضه
لتلك الرسميه عائلته قالت في بيان انه في
السادس عشر من نوفمبر الماضي اقتحم مسلحون
بملابس مدنيه منزلهم في العاصمه طرابلس
واختطفوا ابو عجيله وقت دوه لجهه غير
معلومه عزه اسرته وحينها اختطافها لاغراض
سياسيه ترمي الى الاضرار بالمصالح العليا
للبلاد
اخر محطه لغز اختفاء ابو عجينه كان في
ديسمبر الجاري بعد اعلان الولايات المتحده
ان المتهم المطلوب لديها ابو عجيله بترانا
الاحتجاز لديها دون ان توضح كيف وقع متهم
لكربي بقبضه
[موسيقى]
اليوم ياخذ ابعاد سياسيه والذي اغلق
بالعام 2008 بمرسوم رئاسي يعني ما مساره
القانوني والدستوري بالولايات المتحده
وما الذي سيحصل بالمتهم الذي سلم هنا
بعد اصدار وزاره العدل الامريكيه صباح
اليوم عبر بيان احتجاز صانع القنابل
المزعوم لطائره بنامي
ابو عقيله محمد مسعود خير المريمي
الوزاره اعلنت مسار المسار القانوني عبر
تاكيد انه ابو عقيله سيمثل امام القضاء
الامريكي ولكن في مقاطعه كولومبيا همم في
واشنطن وفقا دائما للبيان البيان لم يحدد
مزيد من التفاصيل ولكنه ذكر انه التفاصيل
ستاتي اتباعا ااه في الايام المقبله خاصه
انه اليوم الاحد عطله نهايه الاسبوع هنا
في واشنطن ليس هناك الكثير من التفاصيل او
الاتصالات التي يمكن ان نكون بها همم ولكن
ما تم تاكيد انه ابعد الى هسه همم يتم
سيخضع للقضاء وتتم محاكمته بمحاكمه
امريكيه على الاراضي الامريكيه البيان
ايضا اشار الى استمرار التحقيقات مع
السلطات سكوتلنديه والبريطانيه حول هذه
القضيه تحديدا واعتقال ابو عقيله
يعني ايضا هناك هناك يعني حمله ضد الحكومه
الليبيه بليبيا لما لخلفيات سياسيه بهذا
الموضوع هناك مطالبه لموقف رسمي حازم بهذا
الموضوع همم ساعات المقبله هل المتوقع ان
يكون هناك اي يعني شيء بالسياسه بهذا
الموضوع وهل ممكن ان يستخدمه الرئيس
الامريكي ايضا كتحقيق نصر همم خصوصا ان كل
الشخصيات التي تعنى بالارهاب عندما يتم
الامساك بها مع كل الرؤساء تستخدم
بالسياسه الداخليه
لا شك انه احتجاز ابو عقيله من قبل
الولايات المتحده هو نقطه مهمه ومحوريه في
السياسه الامريكيه الداخليه
وكما ذكرتيه يمكن ان تستخدم
لتحقيق انتصارات سياسيا ما ولكن حتى
اللحظه لم يذكر تفاصيل عن حول كيفيه
احتجاج ابو عقيله تحديدا وكيف تم التواصل
مع اذا ما تم اصلا التواصل مع الحكومه
الليبيه في هذا الشان ااه كما ذكرنا وذكر
بيان وزاره العدل لانه المزيد من التفاصيل
ستصدر قريبا مع الايام المقبله شكرا لك
اريد تسليما ان نراسله العربيه حدث
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تحت ضغط الاضرابات انهيار كبير للعمله
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه
تويتر فيسبوك انستغرام تيك توك يوتيوب
وغيرها
[موسيقى]
عالم مليء بالمعلومات
والافكار الجديده والحوارات
في كيف بنشوف العالم حولنا
وكيف بنشوف بعضنا وكيف بنشوف انفسنا
في هذا الكون الافتراضي الفسيح
[موسيقى]
ربنا كلكم كل ما هو عاجل من اخبار وطارق
من احداث مثير ومشتعل من تصريحات وجدل
تفاعلكم مع ساره دندراوي من الاحد الى
الخميس السادسه على الشاشه العربيه
بشكل عشوائي على المنازل
هذه المدينه التي تم حصارها لاكثر من
الشهر
هنا في هذه الحفره سقطت القذيفه
هذا هو مسرح والسينما المدينه حصريا
لقناتي العربيه والحدث نرصد ما حدث في هذه
القريه واثار القتال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الحرب الاوكرانيه شن
الجيش الاوكراني هجوما صاروخيا على مدينه
ميليتو بول ذات الموقع الاستراتيجي في
جنوب شرقيه البلاد ما اسفر عن مقتل شخصين
واصابه 10 اخرين وفقا ما اعلنته السلطات
المواليه لروسيا هذا واكد حاكم الذي
عينتهم موسكو للجزء الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا
في مدينه سابوريش انظمه الدفاع الجوي دمرت
صاروخين فيما وصلت اربعه الى اهدافها
واضاف ان مركز ترفيهيا كان ناسيه تناولون
فيه الطعام دمر خلال الهجوم الاوكراني
بصواريخ مارس الامريكيه الهجوم اوكراني
ادى ايضا الى اصابته كنيسه حولها الروس
الى مكان للتجمع في المقابل غرقت مدينه
اوداسه الساحليه في جنوب اوكرانيا بظلام
بعد اطلاق روسيا طائرات مسيره لقصف
منشئتين للطاقه ما ادى الى انقطاع
الكهرباء عن واحد فصل خمسه مليون شخص
ماشي يوصل الامن القومي الروسيه قال ان
موسكو تكثف انتاج اقوى وسائل التدمير
ملوحا باستخدامها ضد الغرب تصريح ياتي وسط
مخاوف غربيه من لجوء بوتن لاسلحه غير
تقليديه ردا على تراجع قوته في اوكرانيا
بينما يرى مراقبون ان روسيا تستخدم سياسه
حافه الهاويه للدفع نحو مفاوضات
عسكريه في الاشهر الاخيره في اوكرانيا
اعاده موسكو لمربع التلويح بتسالتها
النوويه في محاوله لتغيير وضعها الميدانيه
عدونا ليس متواجدا في الخنادق فقط في
محافظتك انه موجود في اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه واليابان واستراليا ونيوزيلندا
وغيرها لهذا نقوم بتكثيف انتاج اقوى وسائل
التدمير
روسيا تقول انها ستلجا لمبادئ جديده لم
توضحها لكن الحديث على الاغلب يدور حول
تكتيك الترهيب الروسي لشبح الحرب النوويه
في محاوله لفرض صفقه مع الغرب الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مربوط باستخدامه تحت ذريعه
ان السلاح النوويه يعد وسيله دفاع الغايه
منها توجيه ضربه الانتقاميه في حال
استهدفت بلاده بهذا النوع من الاسلحه
وروسيا تعمل على تعديل عقيدتها العسكريه
بالاعتماد على الاجيال الجديده من الاسلحه
التي تفوق ابعتها سرعه الصوت حسب البيانات
المعلنه للتسلح النووي العالمي منها التي
نشرتها منظمه ايكان فان روسيا تمتلك اكبر
ترسانه نوويه في العالم اذ يبلغ عدد
الرؤوس النوويه الحربيه لديها سته الاف
وما 2255 راس نووويا منها
1588 جاهزا للاطلاق معظمها صواريخ موجهه
لاهداف بعيده المدى وعدد اخر اصغر حجما
واقل تدميرا تستهدف الاهداف قصيره المدى
في ساحه المعركه او في البحر
وسط التلميح النووي الروسي الدول الغربيه
تقف ممدده باستخفاف روسيا بخطوره الوضع
محضره نياها بعدم استغلال محادثات سلام
اوكرانيا كغطاء لاعاده التسلح او التخطيط
لهجوم اكبر
جيمس بليفري ان اي محادثات بشان اوكرانيا
لا يجب ان تكون فرصه لروسيا لاعاده التسلخ
وفقه تعبير
انا اللي جاي شيشن
مفاوضات حقيقيه ولا يمكن ان تكون مجرد
ورقه لاعاده التسلخ الروسي وتجنيد مزيد من
الجنود سواء من مجموعه فاجنر او من
السجناء في روسيا نريد ان نرى محادثه سلام
لكن يجب ان تكون ذات مغزى وفي النهايه يجب
ان يقرر الشعب الاوكراني والرئيس
الاوكراني محتوى محادثات استلام هذه وهي
العتبه التي يمكن تحقيقها فيما يتعلق
باحلاله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى الوضع الايرادي سنتابع
واياكم هذه الصور المتداوله عبر مواقع
التواصل لحرق عواميد التواصل او المراقبه
في شوارع شيراز في ايران كما نتابعنا
اذا هذه صور متداوله وفيديوهات متداوله
لحرق
اعمده
المراقبه والتواصل بشوارع شيراز جنوبي
ايران طبعا تاتي هذه العمليات وسط تصاعد
التظاهرات الايرانيه ووسط ايضا سياسه
الاعدام التي انتهاجتها السلطات الايرانيه
منذ فتره التي على ما يبدو ستستعملها
كاداه لقمع ويعني ثاني الناس عن النزول
الى الشارع
الى ايران ولا احتجاجات المدعومه
بالاضرابات اظهرت مقاطع مصوره تعدي ضابط
في القوات الخاصه الايرانيه على امراه
اثناء مرورها في منطقه السرخال
احكام الاعداد بحق المحتاجين في ايران لن
تتوقف لا بل ستتصاعد وبقوه فالنظام
الايرانيه سعى بكل جهوده لوقف الاحتجاجات
او تخفيف وترتها على الاقل افادت مصادر
ايرانيه بان السلطات تستعد لتنفيذ حكم
اعدام ثاني بحق احد الموقوفين في سجن رجال
شهر ويدعى مهان صدرك وسط استمرار ردود
الافعال الغاضبه من اعدام المحتاج
الايراني محسن شكاري في طهران وحذرت منظمه
العفو الدوليه من خطر اعدام الشاب معان
بعد شهر واحد فقط من محاكمته في محكمه
الثوره جاء هذا التحذير بعد ما نقلت
السلطات مهام من سجن طهران الكبير الى سجن
رجال شهر استعدادا لتنفيذي حكم الاعدام
وقالت اسرته انها تلقت بلغا بان الحكم
الصادر ضد ابنها دخل مرحله التنفيذ من
جانبها كشفت منظمه هارانا الحقوقيه عن
صدور حكم الاعدام على احد معتقلين
الاحتجاجات في مدينه مشهد شمال شرقي ايران
ويدعى مجيد رضا
رهن ورد طبعا قرار الاعدامات هذا ياتي
كدليل واضح على تاثر النظام الايراني سواء
سياسيا او حتى اقتصاديا فالعمله الايرانيه
خسرت المزيد من قيمتها امام الدولار
الامريكي يبلغ سعر صرف الدولار حوالي
370,000 ريال ايراني
[موسيقى]
هذه هي سمه المدن الايرانيه تظاهرات
المتواصلات تحيط بالنظام وتضرب اقتصاد
البلاد المنهل في مقتل في خدم عقوبات تلو
اخرى
ليتراجع الريال الايراني المتعثر الى
مستوى منخفض جديد مقابل الدولار مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات والاضرابات العماليه
والاسواق وتزيد عزله البلاد وسط
الانتقادات الغربيه للاجراءات الامنيه
الصارمه التي يتخذها النظام تجاه المحتجين
حيث كان يتم بيع الدولار بما يصل الى 300
الف ريال في ما ارتفع بعد الاحتجاجات الى
اكثر من
370,000 ريال
وفقد الريال قرابه 14% من قيمته منذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد عقب
مقتل سامي
قفزه كبيره انعكست هي الاخرى على ارتفاع
الاسعار مع عدم قدره النظام على دفع رواتب
المتقاعدين ما دفع بهم للتجمع في وقفات
احتجاجيه اضافه الى اضرابات في قطاعات
النفط والغاز هو البذر كيماويات في
المحافظات الجنوبيه احتجاجا على الغلاء
والظروف المعيشيه الصعبه والتاخر في دفع
الرواتب
التحام التظاهرات بالاضرابات ذلك ما يخشاه
النظام الايراني الامر الذي قد يؤدي الى
شل البلاد وحركتها الاقتصاديه المناكه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
نعود مشاهدينا لمتابعه مجدده ان الصور
والفيديوهات المتداوله لادرام النيران في
اعمده كاميرات المراقبه بشوارع شيراز
جنوبيه ايران
من لندن معنا الباحث في شان الايراني
وجدان عبد الرحمن
اليوم السلطات الايرانيه تستخدام الاعدام
كاداه سياسيه يعني بموازات التصعيد
الداخلي مع المظاهرات ومميزات التصعيد
الخارجي مع العقوبات الاضافيه على ما يبدو
انها تاتي بنتائج عكسيه كما شاهدنا قبل
قليل ماذا يعني ذلك
نعم بكل تاكيد تحياتي لك ولمتابعيكي
الكرام بكل تاكيد انه كانت النتائج
النتائج عكسيه ليس فقط على صعيد الشارع او
صعيد المجتمع الدولي وانما ايضا حتى على
الصعيد المؤسسه
السياسيه في داخل النظام والمؤسسه الدينيه
في النظام الايراني التي كانت في
الاحتجاجات لم تتحدث عن ما يحدث في داخل
الايراني ولكن بعد اعدام همم محسن شكاري
شاهدنا هنالك ردود فعل همم اتت من قبل
المؤسسه الدينيه واعتبرت هذا الاعدام
بمثابه خطا كبير وايضا حتى خلافا للشرع
وفقا لبعض المراجع همم في المؤسسه الدينيه
في ايران وبالتحديد من مدينه قوم همم
الامر الاخر شعله هنالك بعض المناطق التي
لم
تشهد احتجاجات في الاخيره همم بما فيها
همم موضوع مدينه شيراز عاده لم تكن من ضمن
المدن التي همم
دخلت الى موضوع بشكل كبير ولكن شاهدنا
الان شيراز دخلت على هذا الموضوع اذن
موضوع اعدام محسن شكاري على المنطقه وايضا
المناطق التي كانت في المنطقه الرماديه
بدات تنضم الى الشارع
السياسي والاجتماعي الموجود هناك ازمه
اقتصاديه حقيقيه اليوم كان هناك تقارير عن
عمليات مقايضه لاحذيه لملابس مقابل المواد
الغذائيه وبالتالي كل التصعيد الامني لن
ينفع مع اناس اصبحوا يعني بمرحله الجوع
ماذا يعني كل ذلك من انعكاسات على النظام
وقبضته الحديثيه
بكل تاكيد يعني هذا الامر يجعل هذه هي
الطبقه ايضا
ستنضم الى الشارع عندما يصل الامر الى ان
المواطن يقوم ببيع اعضاء حتى جسده للحصول
على لقمه العيش لا شك انه سينظم الى ااا
ركب هذه الاحتجاجات خاصه وانها اصبحت
اليوم منتشره بشكل كبير وايضا حاجز الخوف
همم انكسر بشكل كبير لذلك هذه همم الطبقه
ستنظم بشكل قوي همم في الوقت الراهن عاده
الطبقه المتوسطه والطلاب الجامعات هم من
دخلوا ولكن في بكل تاكيد هذه الطبقه التي
اليوم تعاني من الجوع ملابسها من اجل لقمه
الايه
العاديات كبيره شكرا لك استاذ وجدان عبد
الرحمن حدثنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
من ايران الى كردستان العراق الصراحه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الحزب الديمقراطيه
الكردستاني محمود محمد بان حزبه برئاسه
مسعود برزاني ابلغ رسميا الاتحاد الوطني
الكردستاني برئاسه طالباني بالاستعداد
لخوض حوار مشترك لمناقشه المشاكل
والخلافات القائمه بين الجانبين مشاهده
على ضروره اجراء هذا الحوار وجاء هذا على
خلفيه انباء متداوله حول مقاطعه وزراء حزب
الاتحاد الوطني للمشاركه في وفد التفاوض
الكردستاني الموجود في بغداد وكذلك مقاطعه
نائب رئيس الوزراء عن الاتحاد الوطني
الكردستاني لجلسات مجلس وزراء حكومه
الاقليم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من اربيل ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عضو الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني محمد زنكنه استاذ
محمد هل يعني تلقى الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الرد على يعني مبادره الحزب الديمقراطي
نعم مساء الخير تحيه لكم ولزملاء
والمشاهدين حتى هذه اللحظه الاتحاد الوطني
الكردستاني لما نسمع منه اي ردحه المساله
مبادره لحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني حول
مساله التفاهم والتفاوض ولكن لا اعتقد بان
الاتحاد الوطني سوف يتنصل او يبتعد عن
مساله الحوار والتفاهم وخصوصا ان الاتحاد
الوطني يعلم جيدا بان للحزب الديمقراطي
ابواب مفتوحه لمسائل الحوار والتفاوض
ودائما كانت الديمقراطي يعني مبادرا لكل
مسائل الحوار والتفاوض اليوم كان يعني حتى
قبل
ظهر اليوم يعني الساعه 12:00 وما بعد
الثانيه عشر كان هناك موقف رسمي من قبل
الاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني بمقاطعه كل
جلسات الحكومه مقاطعه كل الانشطه الحكومه
عدم وجود وفد مسافر مع حكومه اقليم
كردستان من وزراء الاتحاد الوطني
لكردستاني الى بغداد ولكن جاء بعد ذلك
تصريح السيد محمود محمد بين ولطف الاجواء
بين الطرفين وتقريبا خفت المشاحنات
الاعلاميه بين الجانبيه ولكن بكل صراحه
مساله اتخاذ القرار لدى الاتحاد الوطني
لكردستاني تمر بعده فلاتر نظرا لوجود
العديد من الاجنحه داخل الاتحاد الوطني
وداخل المكتب السياسي والقياده هذه من
الممكن ان تؤخر الرد على مبادره
الديمقراطي والا مبادره الديمقراطي واضحه
ولا تقبل الشك بان حسب الديمقراطي وخصوصا
بعد المؤتمر 14 يريد ان يفتح ابواب الحوار
امام جميع الاحزاب والاطراف السياسيه
الكردستانيا وعراقيا
على ماذا تقوم هذه المبادره خصوصا ان
العلاقه بين الحزبين يعني منذ الازال هي
علاقه تنافس وصراع وصلت الى حد استخدام
السلاح بعدد من المرات ما هي البنود التي
سيتم الاتفاق عليها وكيف يمكن ان تنظم
العلاقه بين الطرفين
سيدتي لم يبقى كثيرا لاجراء الانتخابات
مثلا الانتخابات يعني
برلمان كردستان هذا اولا ثانيا المعطيات
الان يعني ليست كما كانت في 80 738 وحتى
تسعينيات القرن الماضي بين الاتحاد والحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني نعم هناك الكثير من
الاطراف اعلاميه والسياسيه تلعب على وتر
الاقتتال الداخلي بين الجانبين ولكن
الحوار بين الطرفين يعتمد اولا على تحريم
الدم الكردي وهذه المساله واضحه وراسخه
منذ توقيع اتفاقيه واشنطن عام 1998 وتوقيع
الاتفاقيه الاستراتيجي بين الجانبيه ثانيا
المساله الثانيه التي من الممكن ان تقوم
عليها هذه الحوارات يعني على الاقل ليعلم
الديمقراطي ما هي المعاتبات التي يحملها
تجاه الحكومه التي هو الشريك فيها اصلا
ثالثا مساله الاختيالات التي تحصل بين
الفينه والاخرى الانشقاقات في المؤسسات
الامنيه ووجود اوضاع تريد ان يعني تنال من
الوضع الامني او تصرفاتنا من الوضع الامني
في اقليم كردستان وخصوصا في مدينه
السليمانيه
تحمل اثارها الى اربيل وخصوصا تصدير
الازمه الداخليه للاتحاد الوطني الى داخل
اربيل والى داخل الحزب الديمقراطي احيانا
وهم يريدون ان يحاولوا ان يصدروا هذه
الازمه ايضا الى داخل حزب الديمقراطي هذه
النقاب من الممكن ان تكون اساسا للحوار
والمباحثات والاهم من كل ذلك الوضع الامني
في اقليم كردستان ووجود شراكه حقيقيه بين
الطرفين ولا ننسى بان هناك لا مركزيه طالب
بها الاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني عليه ان
يعيش بان مساله اللامركزيه تجعلهم هم
المسؤولين عن الاخطاء الموجوده في مناطق
نفوذهم والا فان حكومه اقليم كردستان لن
تكون مسؤوله عن كل شيء
التي سيعتمد عليها المناصب السياسيه
والمحافظه وتقسيم بين الطرفين ايضا هي بند
اساسي بهذا الحوار شكرا لك استاذ محمد
حدثنا من كردستان
[موسيقى]
رغم الحرب التجاريه والصراع الكبير منذ
عقود على ملفات كبرى وفي امريكيه رفيع
يزور الصين لبث الدفع في العلاقات
الثنائيه بين الطرفين
اذن العلاقات التي تدهورت بشكل كبير بعد
ما شن الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب حرب انتجاريه مع الصين كما سيعد
الوفد الامريكي لزياره وزير الخارجيه
انطوني بلينكن للصين المقرره وائل عام
2023 وهي ستكون الاولى من نوعها
لديبلوماسيه امريكيه بارز منذ اربع سنوات
[موسيقى]
الزياره الامريكيه الرفيعه المستوى هي
الاولى منذ الوعد الذي قطعه الرئيسان
الشهر الماضي في بالي والمتمثل ببث الدفء
في العلاقات بين بلديهما في الصين سيتعين
على الوفد اكمال ما بداؤه بايضا بعد
اجتماعه الاخير مع شيعه لها مش قمه مجموعه
العشرين في بالي منتصف نوفمبر لكن ما هي
ابرز الخلافات بين البلدين فلنبدا
مشاهدينا من بؤره الصراع اي بحر الصين
الجنوبي كما نشاهد هنا حيث يحتوي باطن هذا
البحر على احتياطي قد يبلغ عشره مليارات
برميل وعلى ثروه هائله من الغاز الطبيعي
لم تستثمر بعد ويشكل ممر لما قيمته خمسه
تريليونات دولار من التجاره البحريه
العالميه السنويه ولهذا تتمسك الصين
بالسيطره على هذا البحر وهو واقع طبعا
يزعج الولايات المتحده
انتشاريه بين البلدين التي بدات منذ مده
طويله هي لب الصراع بين الجانبين الا انها
تصاعدت بعهد ترامب الذي اججها بانتهاج
سياسات صارمه ضد بكين
بكين بدورها تضغط على اداره لالغاء
التعريفات الجمركيه التي فرضت في عهد
ترامب على منتجاتها خلاف اخر يواجهه
البلدين وهو صناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه
واشباه الموصلات اضافه لحروب الابتكار
وذكاء الاصطناعي التي تشهد فيها الصين
تقدما كبيرا يقلق وعشرها اما تايوان
فتعتبر وتعتبر ايضا من اهم القضايا
الخلافيه بين البلدين حيث تعتبر الصين
طبعا تايوان جزءا من اراضيها التي
ستستعيدها ذات يوم بالقوه اذا لزم الامر
الذي تعارضه واشنطن بشده
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
قتلى وجرحى في
قصفاني من الحدود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد يتعظم قلق اسرائيل من
الجبهه الشماليه التي تشترك فيها مباشره
نحن في الجولان المحتل تزداد خشيه اسرائيل
كثيرا في الفتره الاخيره من امكان ان
تستغل ايران مساعدتها للروس في الحرب على
اوكرانيا لجهه تكثيف التموضع الايراني
داخل الجغرافيا السوريه لهذا التوقعات في
اسرائيل بتكثيف الغرض ضد المواقع
الايرانيه الداخله سوريا لكن لا يقلق
اسرائيل اكثر من ذلك حاليا هو محاوله
محتمله من ايران وفقا بعض المصادر الامنيه
في اسرائيل بتهريب
تقنيات اسلحه دقيقه عبر مطار بيروت لصالح
حزب الله ما قد يؤدي في محاوله اعتراض ذلك
الى حرب شامله مع حزب الله على جبهته
لبنان كما سوري سوريا
وفي الوقت الذي تقول في اسرائيل بان ايران
طلبت من روسيا عوده الامور الى ما كانت
عليه قبل العام 2019 اي اطلاق يد ايران
تماما تموضعا ونفودا داخل سوريا وذلك ايضا
بوضع بطاريات دفاع جويه ايرانيه جديده بدل
تلك الروسيه عمليا على الارض بدات اسرائيل
باستعدادات لحرب المحتمله على هذه الجبهه
من قبيل انشاء مناطق عازله كما في هذه
المنطقه في جباته الخشب حيث توغلت اسرائيل
وانشات شوارع امنيه داخل القرى السوريه
وجرفت بعض المزارع اللافت اكثر بان
اسرائيل اعلن عن مناورات عسكريه شامله في
المنطقه الشماليه تحاكم دلاع حرب متعدده
الجبهات زياد حلبي العربيه المحتل
اعلن الجيش الباكستاني ان القوات من حرس
الحدود الافغانيه شنت قصفان واطلقت نيرانا
كثيفه تسببت في مقتل سته مدنيين واصابه 17
على الجانب الباكستاني من الحدود وقال
الجيش في بياننا القوات الباكستانيه ردت
باطلاق النار عبر نقطه شامان الحدوديه في
اقليم بلوكستان في الجنوب الغربي دون ذكر
تفاصيل عن اي خسائر في الجانب الاخر
[موسيقى]
يوصلوا رجل الاعمال وملك توتر الى ماسك
فضح الممارسات السريه داخل الشركه
والاحداث التي حدثت قبل حذف وتعليق حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب على تويتر
وكشف الجزء الرابع من التسريبات التي
نشرها ماسك ان الرئيس التنفيذي السابق
لشركه تويتر كان في اجازه عندما تم تعليق
حساب الرئيس ترامب وجاء في التسريبات ان
الرئيس الرئيس الشركه طبعا بعثا برساله
الى الموظفين عقب تعليق حساب ترامب اكد
داخل لها ان الشركه بحاجه الى ان تظل
متسقه في السياساتها بما في ذلك حق
المستخدمين في العوده الى تويتر بعد
التعليق المؤقت وكان من المفترض ان نهش
تويتر هو ان يرتكب صاحب الحساب خمسه اخطاء
وهي المهله مع مهله تصحيحيه حتى يتم تعليق
حسابه بشكل كامل وهو ما لم يحدث طبعا مع
ترامب حيث كان لا يزال امام فرصه لتجنب
الحذر وفي الثامن من يناير من العام 2021
تم اعلان تعليق حساب ترامب وذكرت مدونه
على تويتر ان الشركه رجعت تغريدات الرئيس
السابق الاخيره وسياق المحيط بها على وجه
التحديد فيما يتعلق بالاشخاص الذين
اقتحموا مبنى الكابتل بالعنف في السادس من
يناير للعام 2021 واتخذ رئيس توتو الجديد
الى مصر قرارا باعاده حساب ترامب على
تويتر بعد الاستطلاع في الثامن عشر
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في المونديال واصدقاء الانجاز
التاريخي للمنتخب المغربي فوزيه على
البرتغال ووصوله لنصف نهائي مونديال قطر
كذلك الارقام القياسيه للاعبين المغاربه
اثبت الحارس المغربي العملاق ياسين نونو
اول حارس افريقيه يحافظ على نظافه شباكه
في ثلاث مباريات في نسخه واحده من نهائيات
كاس العالم لكره القدم كما ان قفزه
المهاجم يوسف لمصيري التاريخيه عند تسجيله
هدف الفوز على البرتغال تعتبر الاعلى خلال
نهائيات كاس العالم ولا تبلغ ارتفاعها
مترين وثمانيه وسبعين سمرا وفقا لارقام
احصائيه الا انه ياتي ثانيا خلف كريستيانو
رونالدو عالميا الذي بلغت قفزته اثنين
فاصله ثلاثه وتسعين مات عندما كان يلعب مع
ريال مدريد في موسم عام 2012
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عكس اللاعبين الاوروبيين الذين يصتحبون
زوجاتهم اثناء البطولات خطفت امهات لاعبي
كره القدم المغربي اسود الاطلس انظار
العالم في مدرجات المونديال واصبحنا كل
القصه بعد ما سطر اسود المغرب انتصارا
تاريخيا قادهم الى المربع الذهبي في
نهائيات كاس العالم وعندك كل انتصار كان
لا فيتا جدا للعدسات العالميه لجوء
اللاعبين اولا الى احضان امهاتهم هذه
المشاهد وصفها الناس على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ببر الوالدين وتم تداولها على
نطاقنها ساعه مهاجم منتخب بقى المغرب
زكريا ابو فاعل اختار فقط امه لتنزل معه
الى المستطيل الاخضر بعدما تحول الى مساحه
لاحتفالات اسود الاطلس بعد التاهل
التاريخي الى نصف نهائي كاس العالم اشرف
حكيمي ايضا رقد الى والدته بعد صفاره
النهايه يقبل راسها ولم يكتفي هنا بل غرد
بالصور وكتب احبك امي هذه المشاهد المفعمه
بالرضا شاهدناها اكثر من مباراه مع مدرب
المنتخب المغربي وليد الركراكي الذي عانق
والدته بحراره في مدرجات احد ملاعب
نهائيات كاس العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]
حضر الدفاع المدني في السعوديه من عواطف
رعديه مصحوبه بامطار غزيره على منطقه مكه
المكرمه حتى الساعه 10:00 صباحا يوم غد
الاثنين بدورها رفعت الارصاد السعوديه من
درجه تنبيه المتقدم الى التحذير تحسبا
للطوار ايضا حتى صباح الغد
من جده ينضم الينا سلطان السلمي مراسل
العربيه سلطان كيف هي الصوره من هناك
وكل تفاصيل معك تفضل
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه الان بدات زخات المطر في النزول
على جده وكان قدمتها تحديدا قبل ساعه ونصف
من الان في مناطق شمال وجنوب وكذلك عصر
اليوم في شرق جده مركز الوطني لرصاد رفع
او اا نقل حاله التنبيه من التنبيه متقدم
الى الى تحذير سوف تنتهي هذه الحاله غدا
الاثنين في تمام الساعه العاشره صباحا قام
بتاع اداره التعليم جده وجامعه الملك عبد
العزيز وجامعه جدا وكل الكليات الاهليه
والمعاهد التدريب بتعليق الدراسه يوم غدا
للطلاب وكذلك الكوادر او هيئه اعضاء
التدريس في الجامعات وحتى في الكليه نتحدث
انه الدفاع المدني السعودي كان قد اعلن
جاهزيته خلال وصول الى بعض المواقع منذ
ظهور اليوم شاهدنا انتشار كبير لاليات
الدفاع المدني بمختلفه اشكالها ايضا حضر
الدفاع المدني من خروج وقت الامطار فما
تعلق بها الحاله الجويه وقع انه يكون ذلك
امطار من متوسطه الى غزيره مع احتماليه
جريان السيول في محافظه جده وتحديدا في
المناطق الجنوبيه ايضا هذه الحاله سوف
تشمل كذلك سواحل البحر الاحمر جنوب تحديدا
نتحدث على محافظه الليث وايضا القنفذه
التي قامت ايضا اداره تعليم هناك
والجامعات بتعليق الدراسه ايضا الحاله
تشمل مدينه مكه المكرمه اذ قامت كذلك
جامعه ام القرى بتعليق الدراسه ايضا في
هذه اللحظات نشاهد امامكم بعض من زخات
المطر بدات الحاله فعليا وكان يشاهد ايضا
يعني انسيابيه كبيره فيها حركه المروريه
يعني هنالك ووعي كبير من قبل المواطنين
والمقيمين الذي بدا يتوجهون نعم هل يمكن
ان نشاهد يعني ما شاهدناها الاسبوع الماضي
من الفيضانات بالشوارع كما حصل يعني هل
نتحدث عن كميات كبيره من الامطار
الكميات الكبيره التي هطلت على جده مؤخرا
خلال سريع الماضيه هي رقم قياس سجلته
محافظه جده وصول ال187 ملي لا نستطيع
تحديد مقياس نزول الامطار او هطول الامطار
حتى بدل حاله وانتهائها من خلال الجهات
المعنيه وتحديد المركز الوطني الذي يعمل
على نشر محطاته والفرقه الميدانيه لقياس
مستويات هطول الامطار لكن تحديد متقدم
قامت به قام به المركز الوطني للارصاد
لذلك شاهدنا تعليق للدراسه وايضا في كافه
الجامعات والحيوانات
شكرا
متقدمه نعم شكرا لك سلطان السلمي مراسل
العربيه حدثنا من شده
[موسيقى]
بمشاركه اكثر من 350 شركه عامه وخاصه من
15 دوله حول العالم انطلقت في العاصمه
الفنزويليه مناطيد الهواء الساخن في اكسبو
ترانسبورت فنزويلا الدولي للعام 2022
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
الولايات المتحده الحليف الاقدم والاهم
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لكن يبقى ايضا
مهم ان مده الجسور مع الجميع وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه للعربيه امريكا اقدم
حليف لنا لكن من المهم مد الجسور معا
لجميع
صانع قنبله هجوم لقربي مخطوف ومخطف في
ليبيا وظهر معتقلا في امريكا التي تستعد
للمحاكمه
وفي كردستان العراق ضغوط تدفع نحو حوار
ينهي الخلافات السياسيه بين اكبر حزبين في
اربيل والسليمانيه
وماسك يكشف وتسريبات اداره تويتر السابقه
قبل حضره ترامب رئيس مجلس الاداره كان في
اجازه
التاسعه انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله الان الى 360 وزميله
راويه اليك راويه بما ان طاهر يستمتع
بالفرصه
واسبانيا
لي سنتحدث اليوم عن اضراب سائقي الشاحنات
بالاردن والعربيه تتواجد داخل منزل
المهاجم المغربي يوسف انصيري الذي سجل هدف
اسود الاطلس وجعلهم يربحون